you'd be surprised at my days they are
very unstructured no meetings
I don't like meetings I read a lot I
wish I were a faster reader I'd get more
done but I do read a lot and I am on the
phone a moderate amount on themselves
but basically out there my job is
allocating cap that's what I'm thinking
about but I don't like to have things
all packed hour an hour an hour and and
though I are both extraordinarily lucky
I mean we really get to do what we like
to do the way we want to do it with
people that we choose to be around then
they're terrific
I mean we've really got everything our
way and we're very fortunate and in his
world he has a different kind of pace
than I have but we both love it the way
we do it and my guess is that we're each
the most productive in that particular
mode it fits our personalities and
aptitudes what kills great businesses if
you look at I do believe in looking at
history and I like to study failure
actually then my partner says all I want
to know is where I'll die so I'll never
go there and we want to see what has
caused businesses to go bad the biggest
thing that kills them
it's complacency you want a restlessness
a feeling that somebody's always after
you but you're gonna stay ahead of them
always want to be on the move and when
you've got a great business like
coca-cola way the danger would always be
you rest on your laurels but I see none
of that obviously at coca-cola but that
that is the key to compete the same way
when you've got 1.8 billion servings
being sold daily as when you were
selling you know 10 a day and that
restlessness that belief that tomorrow's
more exciting than today you just have
to have it permeate the organization you
just watched two amazing clips and
Warren Buffett take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]